>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
ONE THING WE KNOW FOR SURE ABOUT
ELIZABETH WARREN, ABOVE ALL
ELSE, IS THAT ON ECONOMIC
QUESTIONS, SHE IS A SINCERE
POPULACE.
IF WARREN DEEPLY DISTRESSED BY
ANY INCOME INEQUALITY BECAUSE
SHE PROBABLY JUST TRUST
WALL STREET AND BIG TECH.
SHE HATES MONOPOLIES AND A
MASSIVE MULTIGENERATIONAL
CONCENTRATIONS OF WEALTH.
IF YOU ARE A PRIVATE EQUITY
CHIEFTAIN FOR EXAMPLE OR A WEED
SMOKING TRUST OF FLORIAN LIVING
OFF FAMILY MONEY IN JACKSON
HOLE, YOU HAVE TO BE TERRIFIED
OF ELIZABETH WARREN BUT HOW
COULD YOU NOT BE TERRIFIED?
LISTEN TO HER TALK.
>> NOW THEY HAVE GOT YOUR
FORTUNES AND YOUR MONEY AT
MANAGERS AND THEIR P.R. AND THEY
ARE GETTING RICHER FASTER AND
FASTER AND FASTER AND EVERYBODY
ELSE IS GETTING LEFT BEHIND.
THE WELL TASKS, THE 2% WHILE TA
TAX, GOD, I LOVE THAT WEALTH
TAX.
I'M NOT WILLING TO GIVE UP AND
LET A HANDFUL OF MONOPOLISTS
DOMINATE OUR ECONOMY AND OUR
DEMOCRACY.
IT IS TIME TO FIGHT BACK.
SEE WHEN IT'S TIME TO FIGHT BACK
AGAINST THE MONOPOLISTS WHO
DOMINATE OUR ECONOMY!
SOUND FAMILIAR?
ACTUALLY, THAT'S NOT TOO FAR
FROM MY DONALD TRUMP RAN ON IN
2016 BACK BEFORE PAUL RYAN AND
OF THE PEOPLE GOT A HOLD OF HIS
ECONOMIC PROGRAM.
THIS TIME AROUND, ALL OF THE
FOREIGN PLANS TO STEAL THAT
MESSAGE, THE TRUMP MESSAGE.
WARN CLAIMS SHE IS THE RADICAL
POPULACE, SHE IS THE
DISRUPTOR.
IS SHE?
LET'S SEE.
EMILY IS A WOKE LIBERAL WHO
OFTEN APPEARS ON TELEVISION TO
TALK ABOUT DEMOCRATIC POLITICS.
SHE IS THE DAUGHTER OF TWO
BILLIONAIRES SO YOU WOULD THINK
THAT EMILY WOULD HATE
ELIZABETH WARREN.
SHE DOESN'T.
INSTEAD, SHE DEMANDED THAT YOU
SUPPORT ELIZABETH WARREN OR ELSE
YOU ARE SEXIST.
WATCH.
>> ACTUALLY OVERHEARD SOMEONE
SAY WHAT I THOUGHT WAS
INTERESTING POINT, THAT
BASICALLY IF YOU ARE SUPPORTING
CENTERS OF AS OPPOSED TO WARREN,
IT'S SEXISM BECAUSE SHE HAS MORE
DETAILED PLANS THAT HAVE
EVOLVED.
I THOUGHT IT WAS AN INTERESTING
POINT AND I THINK THERE MIGHT BE
SOMETHING TO IT.
SPOON RIGHT.
IF YOU DON'T SUPPORT WARREN, YOU
ARE SEXIST.
KEEP IN MIND, YOU SELL ONE OF
THE RICHEST PEOPLE ON PLANET
EARTH DEMANDING THAT VOTE FOR IT
WAS WITH WARREN FOR PRESIDENT
BIRDS APPRISING, RIGHT?
IT TURNS OUT MOST OF HER
SUPPORTERS ARE THE VERY PEOPLE
SHE CLAIMS SHE WANTS TO FIGHT.
THAT'S WEIRD.
SO FOR EXAMPLE, IN THE THIRD
QUARTER THIS YEAR,
ELIZABETH WARREN RAISED MORE
MONEY IN SILICON VALLEY FROM
THOSE MONOPOLISTS SHE CLAIMS TO
HATE THAN ANYBODY ELSE RUNNING
FOR PRESIDENT.
SPOTIFY CEO IS AN
ELIZABETH WARREN FAN, SO IS
VENTURE CAPITALIST AND
BILLIONAIRE, CHRIS HOFFMAN.
HE ARTY MAXED OUT TO HER
CAMPAIGN.
THEN LAST MONTH, CHARLIE OVERRUN
FOX BUSINESS REPORTED THAT
ELIZABETH WARREN'S CAMPAIGN IS
MAKING OVER TURNS TO FINANCE
MOBILE'S ON WALL STREET
SEEKING CONTRIBUTIONS.
SOME OF THEM ARE RESPONDING.
WAIT A SECOND, WHY WOULD
ELIZABETH WARREN'S ENEMY IS,
THEY GOT A B ENEMY IS, WHY WOULD
HER ENEMIES ON HER CAMPAIGN?
WE WILL GIVE YOU FIVE SECONDS.
THEY AREN'T REALLY HER ENEMIES.
THEY UNDERSTAND THAT WARREN
DOESN'T REALLY MEAN WHAT SHE
SAYS.
THEY KNOW WARREN'S POPULISM IS A
FACADE AND UNDERNEATH IT ALL
SHE'S REALLY JUST THIS IS
HILLARY CLINTON.